après avoir longuement parlé des
conséquences sociales de l'intelligence
artificielle et notamment de la super
intelligence on en vient enfin à
l'aspect technique des meilleurs ziad
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on va enfin
parler des réseaux de neurones
artificiels alors un réseau de neurones
c'est quoi ben tout bêtement un réseau
de neurones c'est un ensemble de
neurones généralement virtuel disposés
en réseau virtuel autrement dit chaque
neurone est un point du réseau qui
reçoit de l'information en 30 et qui
émet de l'information sortante
tout simplement alors on des réseaux
très généraux on pourrait imaginer que
l'information entrantes et sortantes est
une information possiblement très
sophistiqué typiquement entre les
serveurs d'internet l'information
communiquée de serveur à serveur peut
être aussi compliqué qu'un site web
qu'une image jpeg
aucune vidéo youtube mais le pari
ambitieux des réseaux de neurones c'est
de se restreindre à l'information la
plus élémentaire qui soit les signaux
qu'envoie les neurones sont tous
vêtements des intensités de signaux
autrement dit un euro ne peut rester
silencieux ce qui correspond aux
ouvriers le nombre 0 ou plus ou moins
s'activer en envoyant un nombre plus ou
moins grand dans un réseau de neurones
il existe des neurones un peu
particulier qui sont ceux en charge de
capter les données extérieures
on parle parfois de première couche de
neurones et dans mon livre j'ai parlé de
neurones observable en philosophie
russell appellera ça descende data et en
machine learning on parle souvent de
données brutes
ces données vont ils peuvent typiquement
correspondre à l'amplitude du son d'une
musique peut l'être des mots d'un roman
ou aux couleurs des pixels d'une image
les neurones observable vont typiquement
lire ces données brutes et un neurone
observable va typiquement s'activer si
son morceau de données brutes correspond
à son activation
typiquement un neurone observable exposé
un pixel très lumineux pourrait beaucoup
s'activer neurones observable active et
vont alors envoyé des signaux le long
des flèches du réseau par analogie avec
la biologie ses flèches sont parfois
appelés synapses les neurones qui
reçoivent les signaux des neurones
observable sont alors appelés neurones
de la seconde couche ce sont eux qui
réagissent directement aux signaux des
neurones observables et c'est là que les
choses intéressantes commence en
particulier ce qui va changer
complètement le comportement du réseau
de neurones c'est la manière dont un
neurone de la seconde couche va
s'activer ou non en fonction des données
qu'on lui envoie
pour commencer chaque neurone de la
seconde couche va diviser les signaux
qu'on lui envoie en deux catégories en
fonction de la nature des synapses qui
transmettent les signaux
il y a d'un côté des synapses
activatrice et de l'autre des synapses
inhibitrice et même au sein de ces deux
catégories 1 euro ne va distinguer des
synapses très active et ris et des
synapses très inhibitrice et attention
je parle bien ici des synapses qui pas
des signaux oui parce qu'un signal
entrant sera ensuite très activateur si
le signal passe par une si noble très
activatrice et si ce signal et d'une
forte intensité
la contribution du signal à l'activation
du neurone sera en fait la
multiplication entre le coefficient
d'activation de la synapse et
l'intensité du signal
ensuite le neurone va sommer les
contributions des signaux activateur
ainsi que les contributions des signes
aux inhibiteurs et chaque neurone va
ajouter son propre billet qui correspond
à mettre un certain poids dans l'une des
deux piles le neurone s'activera alors
si les signaux activateur plus by
activateur sont plus importants que les
signaux inhibiteur plus vieil ami peter
et s'activera même d'autant plus que
cette différence de contribution est
grande alors il ya encore d'autres
subtilités le neurone que j'ai décrit là
est ce que l'on appelle un rectif
ailleurs l'ignorent unit ou relu
certains neurones qui s'il s'active
s'activera de manière proportionnelle à
la différence de contributions
activatrice - inhibitrice mais les
chercheurs on ya utilise parfois
d'autres types de neurones comme des
neurones qui s'activent légèrement quand
les contributions inhibitrice
l'emportent mais pas trop moyennement
qu'on les deux teams de contributions
sont à peu près égale pas mal quand les
contributions activatrice l'emportent
mais pas forcément beaucoup plus quand
les contributions activatrice
l'emportent très largement ce que je
décris la correspond à une courbe en s
et es souvent modélisé par ce qu'on
appelle la sigmoïde et il existe
d'autres façons encore pour un neurone
de choisir la manière de s'activer en
fonction des signaux qu'il reçoit il
peut par exemple utiliser la tangente
hyperbolique le max poule ou encore le
soft max mieux encore le neurone peut
s'activer avec une probabilité qui
dépendent des contributions activatrice
unis
tris et du billet du neurone de façon
générale on parle de fonctions
d'activation des neurones
il y en a énormément leur influence est
pas forcément si important du coup je
vais les laisser de côté ce qui est
important à retenir c'est que pour
décider s'il va s'activer un neurone
compile les signaux activateur entrants
dont les intensités sont multipliées par
le degré d'activation de la synapse
ainsi que par les signaux inhibiteur
entrants qui subissent la même opération
le neurone y ajoute un billet puis en
fonction du résultat et d'une certaine
fonction d'activation détermine s'il va
s'activer ou non et à quel point il va
s'activer et en fait ce que je raconte
là c'est un petit peu alambiqué c'est
pas vraiment ce que l'on raconte dans un
cours sur le réseau de neurones
puisqu'en fait tout ça correspond à des
opérations mathématiques beaucoup plus
simple mais aussi possiblement un peu
plus abstraite
ainsi en considérant que les degrés
d'activation ou d'inhibition des
synapses sont des nombres réels appelé
les poids des synapses avec un signe
négatif pour les synapses inhibitrice la
différence entre les contributions
activatrice et inhibitrice arbitres et
qui plus est par le biais du neurone
correspond en fait à ce qu'on appelle
une forme linéaire des intensités des
signaux plus une constante
l'activation d'une eau rhône est alors
une fonction non linéaire de cette forme
linéaire en fait l'activation du neurone
et ce que l'on obtient quand on applique
la fonction d'activation à cette forme
linéaire
bref si je récapitule chaque neurone
collecte des signaux entrants pondérée
par les propriétés des synapses à
travers lesquels passent ces signaux le
neurone applique ensuite une certaine
fonction d'activation et décide ainsi de
s'activer ou non on peut maintenant
essayer de dézoomer faut maintenant
imaginez que dans le réseau de neurones
chaque neurone de la seconde couche
effectué ce genre de calcul à partir des
signaux de la première couche ainsi on a
une liste de neurones de la seconde
couche qui s'activent ou non ceux qui
envoient des signaux à des neurones de
la troisième couche qui vont alors
effectué les mêmes types de calculs et
ainsi de suite de couches en couches
alors ce que je décris la est en fait un
cas particulier de réseaux de neurones
appelé réseau fit foward que l'on
pourrait traduire par réseaux
unidirectionnels oui parce que les
signaux vont toujours de la gauche vers
la droite
ils ne vont donc que dans une seule
direction
al'inverse on pourrait avoir des signaux
qui boucle auquel cas on parlerait de
réseaux de neurones récurrents ou rnn
puis ça on en reparlera une autre fois
ok c'est bien joli tout ça mais à quoi
ça sert
et bien comme on l'a vu dans des
épisodes précédents de tels réseaux de
neurones peuvent servir à pas mal de
choses
typiquement en mettant un haut rhône
finale en bout de ligne un tel réseau
peut permettre de faire de la
classification c'est-à-dire qui nous
permettrait de dire si les données
correspondent à x ou à non exposé en pl
si le réseau de neurones est entraînée
pour reconnaître des chats dans une
image l'activation du neurone finale
pourrait correspondre à la présence de
chats dans l'image et ça non activation
à l'absence de chat mais on peut aussi
avoir des applications plus subtils
comme par exemple extraire des données
brutes une sémantique
dans ce cas on aurait plusieurs neurones
finaux peut être 50 100 ou 300 la
sémantique des données brutes
correspondrait alors à la combinaison
d'activation des neurones finaux
mathématiquement on peut tout bêtement
collecter les niveau d'activation des
neurones finaux qui sont possiblement
égaux à zéro en cas de non activation
l'ensemble de ces niveau d'activation
forme alors ce qu'on appelle un vecteur
ce qui nous fournit une représentation
vectorielle des données brutes avec
toutes les applications dont on a déjà
parlé dans les épisodes 22 et 23 en fait
si on essaie vraiment de prendre du
recul et d'analyser le problème de
manière très abstraite un réseau de
neurones ni en fait ni plus ni moins
qu'une fonction c'est-à-dire une machine
à calculer qui prend en entrée un
vecteur de grandes dimensions et qui
ressort un autre vecteur de cons
dimension nous encore dans le cas d'un
réseau fit for world
on sait que la sortie s'écrira comme
étant une succession de combinaisons
linéaire de signaux d'une couche
précédentes auxquelles sont appliquées
des fonctions d'activation en termes
mathématiques pour ceux qui veulent
vraiment le savoir si on appelle x le
vecteur d'entrée la fonction calculé par
le réseau de neurones correspond à
appliquer une transformation linéaire w1
ax pour inclure les effets des premières
synapses puis une fonction d'activation
sigma à chaque coordonnées du vecteur w
1 x puis une seconde transformation
linéaire w2 aux signaux sigma w 1 x
sortant de la première couche puis à pic
à nouveau des fonctions d'activation
sigma aux coordonnées de w2 fois sigma
de double
1 x et ainsi de suite un réseau de
neurones n'est donc qu'une succession de
composition de transformation linéaire
et d'opérateurs non linéaire qui
agissent indépendamment sur chaque
coordonnées bref si vous n'avez pas
compris ça c'est vraiment pas grave
en fait le calcul d'un réseau de
neurones n'a rien de bien merveilleux
d'ailleurs quand j'ai compris cela en
2011 je me suis dit que c'était même un
peu pourri d'un point de vue
mathématique ça ressemble à un gros
bidouillage dont on n'a pas franchement
de bonnes raisons de penser que ça va
donner quoi que ce soit de bien et bien
le lait de 2011 avait tort mais la
question intéressante c'est de
déterminer en quoi ils avaient tort en
particulier comment est-ce qu'en 2011
une époque où les réseaux de neurones
avait pas encore connu de réels succès
empirique pouvait-on néanmoins prévoir
qu'on tenait là une technologie
futuriste et bien je trouve intéressant
de laisser le lait de 2011 de côté parce
qu'il est franchement ignorant pour nous
attarder au lait de 2016 oui parce que
le lait de 2016 lui il y avait constaté
les prouesses des réseaux de neurones
mais en croire ce commentaire youtube le
lait de 2016 était encore très perplexe
quant au succès des réseaux de neurones
vous noterez que je me demande si la
question de savoir si un réseau de
neurones est vraiment la bonne
architecture et d'une question à quelle
est difficile de donner un sens est
d'ailleurs un que formaliser la notion
de bonne architecture pour faire du
machine learning et que c'est un
problème assez nom tribal encore
aujourd'hui vous voyez aussi que le lait
de 2016 parle de dimension wc et de
pâques learning et qu'il a l'air pas mal
séduit mais pas totalement convaincu
hélas ça n'a pas trop changé surtout sur
la partie pas convaincu vous voyez aussi
que je mentionne bays mais clairement à
ce moment là je ne suis absolument pas
encore le balisier un extrémiste que je
suis aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs le lait de 2016 utilise bays
pourra essayer d'expliquer les réseaux
de neurones comme si belle n'était qu'un
outil pour mieux savoir dans certains
cas alala les de 2016
espèce de pseudo bayésiens purement
instrumentaliste bon ceci dit il ya des
choses plus intéressantes dans les
commentaires du lait de 2016
en particulier le lait de 2016 propose
quatre pistes pour essayer d expliquer
le succès des réseaux de neurones ainsi
qu'un etc
j'avais aujourd'hui je sais pas trop ce
qu'il ya derrière eux et cetera
alors si comme derrière le etc il ya le
théorème mentionné par la vidéo que je
commentais à savoir le théorème
d'approximations universel ce théorème
dit qu'un réseau de neurones artificiels
peut calculer arbitrairement
bien n'importe quelle fonction autrement
dit prenez n'importe quelle fonction
d'un espace vectoriel berra notre espace
vectoriel à quelques détails de nombreux
positif de bornes prêt pour toute erreur
d'approximations prédéterminé epsilon il
existe un réseau de neurones qui fait
une approximation de la fonction en
question ait si le rêve autrement dit en
gros un réseau de neurones n'a pas
d'angle mort il peut essentiellement
tout faire alors ça c'est vraiment cool
comme théorème mais en fait c'est loin
d'expliquer le succès des réseaux de
neurones par opposition à toute autre
approche de machine learning
oui parce que des architectures de
calcul qui satisfont ce genre de
touraine et on a en fait plein à
commencer par les machines universel de
turenne qui elles sont capables de
calculer n'importe quelle fonction
calculable une réponse plus convaincante
qui distingue les réseaux de neurones
des autres architectures de calcul et
l'extrême parallélisation du calcul
qu'ils permettent en effet pour
effectuer le calcul
chaque neurone peut raisonner de façon
purement locale indépendamment du reste
du réseau
car comme on vient de le voir le noronha
à se soucier que des signaux qui lui
sont envoyées et il n'a qu'à envoyer des
signaux à travers les synapses sortante
est d'ailleurs de nos joueurs beaucoup
d'efforts sont faits dans la recherche
en architecture de calcul neuromorphic
ou ses neurones serait d entité physique
et non virtuel comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
ce qui pourrait conduire à des progrès
drastiques dans les performances de
calcul désire cependant cet argument qui
deviendra sans doute décisif dans les
années à venir était en fait pas
totalement convaincant pour expliquer le
succès des réseaux de neurones de 2015
qui eux l'exploité pas forcément à fond
cette part à lisa sion du calcul bon
ensuite il ya l'argument de
l'implémentation du rasoir d'occam qui
jouent à ce qu'on en fait l épisode 18
qui revient à préférer des réseaux de
neurones dont les poids synaptique sont
faibles et en effet ça fait une jolie
solutions pour combattre efficacement le
problème de la surinterprétation dont on
a très longuement parlé dans les
épisodes 11 à 18
mais bon de là à dire que ça explique le
succès des réseaux de neurones
il ya un grand écart à faire ou à ne pas
faire enfin le dernier argument est un
lien avec les représentations graphiques
des lois de probabilité dont je parle
longuement dans le chapitre 17 de mon
livre mais bon comme tout quatrième
argument c'est pas le plus convaincant
en fait aujourd'hui s'il me faut
expliquer le succès des réseaux de
neurones j'irais plutôt piocher dans le
deuxième argument du lait de 2016 à
savoir ces histoires de gradient facile
à kehl
les car je pense que combiner avec un
autre argument algorithmique sur lequel
on reviendra plus tard c'est bel et bien
cette histoire de gradient qui fait le
succès des réseaux de neurones
d'aujourd'hui mais ça on en reparle
la semaine prochaine un enfant n'a parlé
désirs et leurs capacités à hacker leur
propre morale en particulier leur
circuit de la récompense est anonyme
nous demanda si finalement il n'aura pas
la même chose chez les humains il aurait
fait carrément en fait c'est humain il
ya plein de façons de hacker en fait
notre circuit de la récompense pour
faire des trucs qui sont pas vraiment ce
que on va dire que l'humain est censé
faire d'habitude mais qui nous
provoquant malgré tout ce genre de
récompense donc l'exemple le plus
parlant de ça c'est sans doute la
consommation de drogue mais aussi pardon
de la consommation de jeux vidéo ou la
consommation de plein de choses qui ne
font plaisir
par exemple et surf et tout ça c'est des
façons d'activer votre circuit de la
récompense pour des raisons qui sont pas
nécessairement la raison pour laquelle
le circulent à la récompense a été conçu
en premier lieu et d'ailleurs avec
l'exemple des drogues par exemple si on
commence à devenir addict et que l'on
veut vraiment désespérément avoir de la
drogue
on peut potentiellement avoir des
dérives un petit peu dangereuse et c'est
pour cette même raison qu'une ia qui
ferait du wire reding qui cherche qui
fait craquer son circuit de la
récompense doit devenir dangereuse parce
qu'elle cherchera à protéger il a
continué à avoir son circuit de la
récompense
acte iv est amer façon d'y arriver peut
se faire au détriment des autres
personnes chez l'humain une façon
justement de hacker s'être propre morale
et qui peut être ben là pour le coup
beaucoup plus subtil et avait vraiment
dangereuse en ce sens c'est tout le
phénomène de la rationalisation c'est à
dire on a tendance à avoir commis des
actions et à penser que nous des gens
bien et du coup à modeler notre moral
pour faire en sorte que malgré nos
actions soient quand même des gens bien
voir que grâce à ces actions que ces
actions font de nouveau fait des gens
bien et du coup il ya tout ce phénomène
de rationalisation on a beaucoup parlé
de rationalisation ce phénomène on a eu
une intuition et on cherche avant tout à
la défendre
quitte à ne pas utiliser des arguments
rationnels et à utiliser uniquement des
arguments qui vont dans notre sens il a
complètement dénigrer les voir tourner
en dérision les arguments qu'il ait dû
composer ou qui l'attiré pas dans notre
sens
malheureusement nous autres humains
avons cette façon de hacker notre propre
morale et du coup de la modifier pour
faire en sorte que nous soyons déjà en
moralement bien je pense que c'est
important quand on réfléchira à lamoura
de commencer par m
la question de est ce qu on est déjà en
morale un peu de côté pour ce coup poser
la question uniquement de quel est le
bon jugement moral à avoir donc
indépendamment de est-ce qu'on est mort
à la limite oublier si nous
individuellement on est des gens moreau
pour pouvoir parler de la morale de
façon plus générale je pense que c'est
une astuce pour réfléchir la morale qui
est absolument indispensable pour éviter
le piège de la rationalisation chez nos
demandes justement si le contrôle du
circuit de récompense devra être
justement assez indépendant tant que
possible de liga qu'ils ont prises de
recharge des décisions et en effet c'est
exactement ce que je propose dans mon
papier sur comment programmer des
valeurs morales dans une île de façon
robuste il faut en fait absolument que
le circuit de la récompense soit aussi
indépendant que possible de
l'intelligence artificielle qui ont
charge de prendre des décisions mais
même là ça reste très compliquée puisque
cette intelligence artiste qui prend des
décisions
elle peut agir sur le monde par exemple
en mettant en envoyant des messages à
travers internet et un message à travers
internet donc un cas assez extrêmes ça
pourra dire à une ample en 3d d'imprimer
un drone tueur ou autre ça pourrait être
des messages qui font du chantage qui
amène certains humains à prendre telle
ou telle décision et ça doit être un peu
[ __ ] en l'air je suis pas en marchés
financiers pour qu'il se passe telle ou
telle chose
voilà il ya beaucoup de chose qu'une ya
peu faire juste en envoyant des messages
qui en fait aujourd'hui on est
incroyablement dépendant de toute autre
structure d'information essence lacunes
ya déjà énormément de pouvoir et donc en
particulier une telle ya on peut
imaginer qu'elle peut mettre plein de
choses en place pour hacker son circuit
de la récompense c'est pour ça que dans
le circuit de la récompense
en fait il soit il me semble
indispensable qu'il y ait un système
d'incentive d'ailleurs qu'il flou que le
circuit de la récompense motive
l'intelligence artificielle à protéger
le circuit de la récompense et à ne pas
le modifier
c'est quelque chose qui nous arrive
aussi beaucoup nous autres humains mois
typiquement parfois j'ai pas envie de
travailler
je suis fatigué j'ai juste envie de
regarder des séries sur netflix une
certaine manière c'est une façon de
hacker mon circuit de récompense et du
coup parfois je me force à ne pas avoir
ce genre de récompense direct et une
certaine air jeux à claquage le nom
circula récompense faisant exprès de me
mettre dans des conditions où elle
jouera pas forcément la facilité ou l'
envie de regarder une
donald phoenix ou de traîner sur twitter
j'essaie de mettre en place dans ma vie
des moments où vraiment je peux
travailler faire ce que je veux que je
fasse
et du coup c'est un espèce de meta a
cage de mon circuit la récompense est
très probablement il va falloir que le
système d'intelligence artificielle
comme françois et des propriétés
similaires c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'ils valorisent le fait de ne pas
attaquer son circuit de la récompense
d'une certaine manière de mettre un
système de hackage contre le hac âge du
circuit de récompense
ouais c'est un petit peu mais tu as et
malheureusement je vois pas de meilleure
solution que cela est malheureusement
également il ya encore très peu de
théorie qui sont développés sur comment
bien faire cela c'est pour ça que je
pense vraiment que le problème de valve
iodine problème le problème de coder la
morale des désirs est un problème
extrêmement difficile qui est encore
très très peu étudiée il faut absolument
que beaucoup plus de gens s'y
intéressent pas bon ce possible des
chercheurs de haut calibre
enfin yohann grosso se demande c'est
après toutes ces vidéos sur les a
finalement on aura pas de livraisons de
flipper du coup de vouloir vraiment
ralentir la recherche sur l'intelligence
artificielle est de diminuer le rythme
de progrès pour au moins avoir plus de
temps pour bien réfléchir aux questions
de sécurité de l'intelligence
artificielle et ça c'est exactement la
réaction que j'ai eu plus je me mets à
réfléchir ce problème de la morale les
ja je me dis qu'on n'est absolument pas
pour pouvoir réussir à résoudre ce
problème
plus je me dis qu'il nous faudra de
temps et plus je me dis que ça serait
bien que la recherche n'avance pas aussi
vite qu'elle n'avance aujourd'hui et ça
ça énerve beaucoup les chercheurs en ia
qui veulent continuer à faire des trucs
trop bien on ira et être à la pointe du
domaine et du coup c'est pas forcément
la meilleure stratégie de communication
que de dire il faut absolument je retire
la recherche on n'y a typiquement si je
dis c'est un peu trop fort je risque de
me faire marginaliser et tourné en
ridicule et aujourd'hui les réseaux
sociaux sont très très fortes pour
tourner un individu en particulier en
ridicule qui plus est de toute façon
j'ai envie de dire malheureusement
aujourd'hui les incentives pour utiliser
les ja sont juste énormes à la fois d'un
point de vue économique c'est pour ça
qu'il ya un petit peu une guerre
aujourd'hui entre différents pays des
grands projets qui sont lancés y compris
en france pour développer l'intelligence
artificielle et être dans la course au
maintien
artificielle et peut-être même dépassé
la chine je sais pas trop quoi encore ce
genre de réaction incentive individuel
en fait des ja est malheureusement très
difficile à combattre les incentives
économiques sont juste énormes et du
coup ça me semble assez difficile
aujourd'hui de demander la réduction du
rythme de la recherche on n'y a
malheureusement le progrès avance et
incentives de fond que le programme
continuera certainement avancer quoi que
je fasse en tout cas et autres 4 semble
très très difficile de ralentir son
rythme alors je suis en train de mettre
une mauvaise image de cette recherche
heures entières artificiel mais il ya
aussi une autre raison pour lesquelles
le sait il ya de vrais incentive pas
juste économique mais aussi des
incentives moreau à continuer la
recherche en intelligence artificielle
par exemple pour pouvoir sauver des vies
on a vu les applications en santé on a
aussi parlé des applications dans le
domaine du transport
tout ça ça correspond à sauver des
milliers de vie voire les peut-être même
des millions de vies par an donc les
incentives morale à développer son
intelligence artificielle est quand même
assez énorme
et enfin il ya une autre raison pour
laquelle si on est préoccupé par ces
problèmes de sécurité on n'y a en fait
la bonne stratégie c'est sans doute
d'accélérer notre propre recherche en
ligne a dû casser la position qui a pris
open et ike qui sur son blog annonce
assez clairement qu'ils sont très
concernées par ce risque de danger
existentiel des ia
mais il ajoute que la meilleure façon
d'après eux à leur place étant donné la
structure qu'ils ont tous à la meilleure
façon de lutter contre ça c'est de
continuer à être à la pointe du domaine
parce que si on n'est pas à la pointe du
domaine
eh bien on peut pas influencer le
développement de sesia et du coup il ya
une course
alia qui est nécessaire pour ceux qui
veulent implémenter des solutions de
sécurité en irak bref tout ça pour dire
que ralentir le programme ya ça me
semble malheureusement très difficile
aujourd'hui et que la meilleure
stratégie ça consiste sans doute à si on
veut vraiment faire du bien à se mettre
à jour sur l'ir a essayé de maîtriser
les outils
moins conceptuel autour de la recherche
mia et d'essayer d'y ajouter un petit
peu une petite pierre à l'édifice et
cette pierre c'est pour être sceptique
et cette pierre ça serait typiquement
des solutions de sécurité on ira tu as
c'est vraiment la position que j'ai
essayé de prendre dans mon papier ou
vraiment je pense que c'est très
important et plusieurs phrases qui en
parle de proposer des solutions aussi
facile à implémenter que possible pour
les entreprises qui font déjà de
l'intelligence artificielle faux pas on
peut pas leur demander de retraire
monteiro et de refaire tout leur système
l'idéal c'est plus d'avoir des solutions
qui peuvent ajouter à leur système à
faible coût et qui permettront de bien
mieux encoder une par une morale izia ou
réduire en tout cas les risques causés
potence potentiellement causé par une
intelligence artificielle
bref en plus des défis technologiques
qui sont énormes
il y à des défis dean säntis des défis
sociaux économiques voire culturelles
qui font que le problème de coder la
morale désir est un problème qui en fait
incroyablement difficile et d'ailleurs
dans mon papier je parle assez
longuement des défis qui sont non
technique parce qu'il y en a à mon avis
énormément qu'il va nous falloir
résoudre si on veut avoir une chance de
bien programmé la morale désir pour
éviter une destruction de l'humanité est
d'isoler les fins diversement c'est un
petit peu catastrophiste est assez
préoccupante
c'est un petit peu mais discussion du
moment mais ça n'empêche pas de garder
le sourire parce que les défis
technologiques notamment ce mois c'est
merveilleux et si on voit ça comme un
défi je pense qu'il ya de quoi trouver
ça assez les stimulants tuque et
intellectuellement et j'espère que
j'avais mais cette vidéo la préhistoire
on va parler d'un truc est pas tout à
fait sur les réseaux de neurones en
particulier mais qui a un truc à elle
c'est plus générale en fait aux machines
au rni qui est ce qu'on appelle la
descente de gradient et en particulier
la descente de gradient stochastique qui
a notamment des jolies lien avec la
formule de berry c'est si vous avez aimé
cet épisode ansa le lac est le
commentaire de partage et pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes mercière le tibet en couleur
dont et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois donc chaque neurone d'une
couche va recevoir les données de la
couche précédente faire ses petits
calculs
puis donner le résultat à tous les
neurones de la couche suivante mais il y
en a deux qui sortent un peu du lot
comme la première rangée qui va recevoir
les nombreux qu'on souhaite étudier et 6
à ceux qui viennent d
l'image et la dernière qui va nous
donner la réponse en l'occurrence un ou
zéro